all Bree asks do you think you have to
come up with an original idea to have it
be considered art or can you do
something in the creative field really
well without having to reinvent the
wheel I'm a food photographer and I feel
like I can't come up with a different
idea to photograph a cheeseburger
but I can photograph it so that it looks
delicious and it makes my clients happy
do you have ideas on how to gain
inspiration without looking at Pinterest
or other people's art well I mean if
you're a food photographer and we were
just talking about this before we even
started like we're all food
photographers now we should send a
connecting email to her and Andrew
Andrew Bell who for a period of time had
a great food podcast called stem ah but
he is he's actually a good food
photographer angel yeah he's a great
he's a great he's a great chef in from
what I hear and he's he's a great
photographer food he's also an
incredible artist yeah I'm really good
he's got the Triple Threat he really
does and somehow he's able to balance
those things he's one of the most
talented musicians today for sure and
creates these these beautiful bodies of
work that stand alone and put then also
on his free Tommy photographs his own
meals yeah does it have to be original
to be considered art that's the question
right what about like you know think of
Warhol's work right you know they're
they've like the the Campbell's soup
series which in and of itself it's a
it's a simple painting rendering of a
soup can with different colors right but
it pulls various emotions from the
viewer it's it's it's simultaneously
original and not original I think so we
had Andrew Andrew Schultz on the show
he's a comedian and one things that he
said that really stood out to me he said
the thing is we're not comfortable with
it is and it isn't
is it original yes is it not original
yes I think both of those things can be
true so I'm the world is not by an area
the
world is not black and white I think if
she is finding enjoyment if she's
finding some inspiration in it sure I
don't know who they is in this you know
who is they anyway
who's considering an art or not
considering I don't know why that
matters but Seth Godin says you make
make work you care about for people who
care about it I'm probably butchering
that quote but but ultimately it's like
what are you fine to be meaningful and
then you're making it for people who
actually care about enough for people
who wouldn't consider it to be art there
he's making it for her own joy chances
are it's gonna end up being art because
she's doing it for the joy of making it
if she's doing it for a client that
needs a cheeseburger photographed
effectively colorfully and rich detail
it's fulfilling its objective and that's
cool too
yeah you know doing good there's a lot
to be said for doing good work right and
in there there's something by the way if
your client finds it to be meaningful
and useful then that's what you're
trying to accomplish anyway I mean
unless you're not unless you ultimately
don't want to take on client work
anymore and then that's that's something
else but if you are taking on client
work understand there you want to be
able to express yourself through your
art but they're also going to have
expectations and that's okay if they're
paying you for the work yeah
you